dc fandom hall of heroes main trailer
released today and apparently there's a
new schedule as well i think it's being
divided up into a couple of days
excuse me if i'm still a little sweaty
went on an intense run
in 100 degree weather yesterday
mcdonald's uh had a deal for one dollar
large fries i had a lot of large fries
so i had to sweat it all off
how many dollars did you spend too many
dollars
no exactly two two dollars two dollars
too many dollars
on two times let's see what's in store
so excited for this event
[Music]
august already comes an unprecedented
global fan event
those are all the zoo
[Laughter]
before meetings actually standing inside
a stage
that jim lee himself drew how incredibly
[Applause]
cool
[Music]
there's no way that i could come here
and not bring a look at the
confirmed
impossible ends up becoming possible
hang on tight because we are about to
list you around the dc fandom
are you guys ready let's get this thing
fandom started of heroes all fans
welcome
24 hours only august 22nd and there's
only
one place you can experience it i just
signed up
this morning he just signed up
so excited for this man that was
exciting as a movie trailer
okay so there's official confirmation
that batman footage
will be there yeah i mean there's
already been some confirmations of other
stuff like the rock showing up to talk
about black adam what's the sk
that's the schedule so it's been split
into two days
wonder woman 1984 10 a.m we're not gonna
cover
everything but you know like the main
trailers if there's any big news
hopefully there's a man of steel two
announcement that's what i'm really
hoping for
suicide squad 11 55
snyder cut panel at 2 30. this is
literally gonna be
all day that we're doing this suicide
squad kills
the justice league no there's an
official title for it
i realized that as of now as of this
schedule okay cool
and then there's a bunch of encore ones
as well
so much to look forward to kind of map
our schedule accordingly and then the
batman actual footage all right guys
well you make sure to subscribe and
click that notification bell this is
gonna make up for
the lack of comic con excitement this is
the best thing to probably come out of
2020 this year
doing so much dc pump me up man re-read
the long halloween this week
watched like a couple of the dc animated
movies i just borrowed injustice 2 to
play the story line
so much going on i finally watched the
bvs ultimate edition
there you go yeah and it was pretty
good so you heard it here subscribe
click that notification bell we'll catch
you guys soon